every esport has its fair share of
iconic caster calls moments that will be
remembered for years to come some of
them are hyped
[Applause]
others are well
a little more interesting
brandon versus potter first to
ten baby philly
sometimes casters do or say things that
are so ridiculous we just can't help but
laugh so this week we wanted to look at
some of their funniest and weirdest
performances but before we get started i
gotta remind you to hit the subscribe
button and the notification bell and now
buckle up because today we are counting
down the top 10 weirdest caster moments
in esports history
kicking off our list we have some
interesting improv from street fighter
casters yipes and lee chung you'll go
fire
oh clingy
oh go go go go i don't know why i'm
making a crate sound but it just sounds
official go go
at nlbc54 way back in 2017 yipes and lee
chung noticed there were some technical
difficulties in a match between smug and
sabin somehow there was no audio so the
two commentators took matters into their
own hands oh we don't got no audio this
is crazy right now
these are quiet duffs these are silent
duffs these guys are some of the most
coded commentators in the fgc and this
was just another example of why everyone
loves them
that's the fire
wait a minute why was that a helicopter
that's what he did
coming in at number nine is a moment of
honesty from pansies
during ballarat's first ever eu versus n
a land showdown team look at soulcast
made a truly unbelievable miss play it
was so bad that pansy had immediately
seen enough it's all about them trying
to bide the time towards as well i've
got to hinder this approach and soul
cass the flank's so good here does he
decide to go for this
team liquid manager here you just delete
the game please
version 1 and vanity went on to win the
match but not before vanity rubs things
in a little for soulcast some i don't
know oh he's knife again he's diving
yes
oh my god
[Laughter]
at number eight we have a sleepy moment
in esports history
hey you good after a match between young
ha and geobraun at nec 2021 commentator
swag 740 realized that his
co-commentator had fallen asleep live on
the broadcast strong showing geobrand
you love to see the spider-man
hey you good
yo
luke you good
[Music]
know
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're pretty sure this is the first time
in esports history that a commentator
has fallen asleep live on air during a
tournament amesburth later explained
himself saying that his wild day of
travel and casting caused him to be up
for 24 hours straight
he just couldn't help but take a snooze
singing his way into the number seven
spot we have league of legends caster
mark z
all right vancouver
you know this song it is tradition i
want everyone to get hyped get involved
and sing along with me
[Music]
every league fan knows that when a
series goes to five games it's time to
bust out the silver scrapes but at the
2017 nalcs spring finals mark z tried to
make league's game 5 anthem just a
little more special he wanted the crowd
to sing it with him the problem is
silver scrapes doesn't have any lyrics
but mark z made it work
well kinda
yeah we're gonna make you listen to that
again
[Music]
the crowd responded well but i think
they were more excited to watch an epic
game five between tsm and c9
punching its way into the number six
spot we have one of the most iconic
caster calls in fgc history
keep it basic that's not gonna work
that's one more
otg bionic arm giving
he has another chance
back at final round 14 in 2011 ultra
david absolutely lost his [ __ ] during a
winter semi-finals match between marin
and combo themed the clip has amassed
nearly 800 000 views and fans keep
coming back to relive this hilarious
moment
at the halfway point on our list we have
ddk bard off and threat showing off the
guns
we're here totally live from valencia
you guys how's it going it's not bad not
bad then it's not bad i've even got
my flip-flops
nice
now in esports the talent isn't always
on site at the event so at dreamhack
masters in 2015 in valencia these three
casters decided to have a little bit of
fun dressing up in tank tops so they
could at least feel like they were in
spain they also gave us an interesting
warning about buying sunglasses from
british retailer poundland oh yeah
please if you buy sunglasses as
poundland they actually enhance hamza
hassan's the uv light which increases
the risk of getting cancer
so don't don't buy those right
in our number four spot we have an
awkward moment from cyclops come come
you hadouken come in me what did he say
cyclops is probably best known for his
work as a polarizing dota 2 caster man
where is the where there is a will days
away team fanatic have been trying to
kill that guy that antimatter is so hard
to kill even harder than the osama bin
laden but he made a brief appearance
commentating street fighter 5 at tiger
uppercut 2018 where he had more than a
few bizarre calls on the mic
come come you hadouken come in me just
keep going smell me feel me here we go
he's so good at it this guy i think he
should go play baseball or something
very good at catching ball
look at that
there's no way you can break through all
these orbs and use the paraben i'm on
fire at least the community seemed to
love him
in our third spot we have kickstar the
esports community has been mourning
after his tragic death in october but
the siege caster left us with some
unforgettable calls one of his funniest
moments was from an n a league match
between beast coast and except back in
june of this year and 25 seconds to plan
this could be a massive clutch for beast
coast the plant going down bio has to
cover and he's gonna do a great job of
it but no jarvis drops from ceo bio
still has time to win the fights but why
are you sprinting bio it's safe to say
that kickstart was a little confused by
this play but this kind of authentic
reaction is just one of the many reasons
the c community loved his casting bio
still has time to win the fights but why
are you sprinting bio
in our runner-up spot we have the anthem
of dota 2 lakhad madata
fnatic pulled off an insane comeback at
iem katowice 2018 but the game's
filipino casters stole the show while
most people listened to the english
broadcast at the time the tagalog stream
ended up becoming a meme in the
community valve later honored casters
lon and dunno by adding their famous
call as a chat wheel option
unfortunately dino passed away earlier
this year but it's safe to say his
legacy will be remembered by the dota
community forever you know i do want to
personally thank our canadian neighbors
putting on an event like this when you
have people coming from 64 different
nations is really challenging so
to canada
in our top spot we have the sweetest
caster bromance in all of esports quick
shot and deficio
trevor
kiss me
since the early days of the eu lcs these
two lovebirds have been the ultimate
broadcast power couple but when deficio
left his role as a caster to take on a
role with origen quickshot was
heartbroken and back in spring 2015
finals
he asked me to kiss him
and i did and it was magical and it was
amazing and for three years two months
five days 22 minutes and now 17 seconds
we had the most amazing relationship
luckily the two have since been reunited
deficio still shows up from time to time
on the lec broadcast to see his one true
love quick shot how often he thinks that
you think about him that's i know that's
a bit of a
the problem is the actual answer i don't
think i can say on air
all right folks that's our list for
today if you think we miss anything let
us know down in the comment section
below take care and i'll see you in the
next one
exciting that for you at this point
we'll see the pistol coming through
naughty defensive and he nails the first
shot second maybe the third get right
trying to find some form here rez will
be with norkie and looks like the bombs
down and can get right even get close to
him he's gonna give it a good shot
north's found another one anybody else
no no he's going for the ac
he's got the 6k
unbelievable
six kills in the round